What's up guys, this is episode four of me training my little sister for her half Iron Man.
We're gonna go back to Run Club.
Hi, how come you doing the vlog today?
Where's John?
John's not here.
John's not here, so I got the vlog.
Oh, this is behind the scenes of DJ Bear Real.
What do we got?
What's the plan, Bear?
What's the plan?
I'm doing a series with Runko.
Oh, I've seen it.
Yeah, yeah.
It's all over my age.
We just need someone to hold my phone.
I can hold the phone.
I think that was pretty good.
I'll be cameraman.
I'll be cameraman today.
You get me on camera and I say hi back.
Happy Saturday everyone!
Welcome to Run Club!
Thank you so much for coming out!
Give yourself a round of applause!
As always, we have a one-mile loop.
You can do it up to three times.
We're gonna start here.
We're gonna do the same loop as we always do.
Yeah, thank you for coming out.
We're gonna do one big group photo, so if everybody can come over this way, we'll take it from here.
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
This is what you expected to do in the weekend.
Low key, yeah.
Low key, you ready for it?
I mean, if I'm home on a Saturday, I gotta go to Brunswick.
How far do you run?
Three, but I'm gonna do another point, one to do a 5k.
Like ten seconds after I post it.
There's this kid named Aiden that will comment with literally with ten seconds of every time I post it.
I need the kudos, right?
Bear, you need the kudos?
I've been doing the yeah to you too.
You've been doing the yeah chain to her too?
Yeah.
Looking like you worked hard.
Five?
Yes, sir.
Heck yeah.
Are you going for a pacing?
We're like 730 probably.
Okay.
650, man.
650.
Dude, the winter hat is bold, bro.
Respect, and a pen.
This is amazing.
You guys should come out to the Noir Anderson's Run Club.
It's amazing, the community I've found.
People I've met, it's been amazing.
I'm so grateful for you to make this happen.
Yeah, thanks for coming out.
As always.
Bro got cooked.
He's staring at me from across the way.
What's happening?
What are you guys talking about?
We're just making fun of you.
You ain't nothing.
This is actually Faith Anderson's run club.
Maybe it should be.
It's not yours anymore.
Run club was successful.
Do you have fun?
Very successful.
Very fun.
We got a swim later today.
Alright, outdoor swim or indoor swim?
Before dinner.
Are we going to the poker dinner?
Is that a bet?
It's a very wide angle.
Got this new zoom lens.
One of the reasons I wanted to rip a vlog today was that in a month I'm going to be in Europe for four weeks and I want to try to do a daily long form YouTube video so I just want to get some practice like...
Doing a vlog because I've been working with a videographer for the past year, so I haven't spent a lot of time talking to a camera.
It can be kind of awkward.
Hopefully this isn't awkward.
I received one of the goofiest PR packages I've ever received.
From Peel's Citrus.
I already ate some of the mandarins.
They sent me two of these, but I got a hat.
What do you think?
You got a mandarin PR package.
That is the second time.
I have gotten stuff from Halos before.
And now peels.
We grow a lot of androids and you eat a lot of androids.
Feels like we should know each other.
It's so funny.
It's like, what is my life?
You should have liked it.
It's kind of tough.
Peel citrus.
Thank you for that.
I also got my monthly transparent labs supplement supply drop.
These broaching bars.
Gonna send Faith home with some because she loves them.
They are fire.
Use code NOAA for 10% off.
Let's head out to... where are we going?
She's gone out of here for saying use code NOAA.
Code NOAA, code NOAA, code NOAA.
We're going to brunch now.
My friend Reagan's a chef and she's chefing us up some food for brunch and then we're gonna go swim after that.
So, let's get... actually I'm gonna put them... I'm gonna rip a mandarin and put the mandarins in the fridge.
It's the play.
The peels mandarins.
We gotta review the Strava comments so far.
How many yeas do we think?
I tell everybody in my Strava comments section to go comment ye and face post whenever she posts.
But now people will naturally show up.
When you don't tell them to, I only get 47s.
But I did get 180 kudos.
180 kudos.
That was your fastest 5k.
Is she actually going to do the Iron Man?
I don't know.
We'll find out.
Are you going to do it this summer?
I don't know.
We'll see.
We'll find out later today after this one work out.
Anderson behind the camera.
No Jay Sandy today.
No Jay Sandy.
What's up?
How are you?
What is this?
Oh my goodness.
This is insane.
What even is that?
You just got to get a friend who's a private chef.
She cooked.
She's literally incredible.
Down to the menu.
Okay, this is crazy.
I met you.
Oh, I'm so excited for this, especially.
This looks so good.
Oh my gosh, it looks... it smells... the smells right now.
We got... we have... we have a mania.
No shot.
She's amazing.
So same time tomorrow morning and the next morning and the next day for the new restaurant to show up to this like once a week.
Like I'd pay... I would too.
J-Sandy's not coming, unfortunately.
This is... this is an honor right here.
For the green juice?
Was it Ryan or John?
You asked for the green juice.
Alright, well then this is for you Peter.
Kale, celery, kiwi, and apple.
You get first pour.
Good 9.8 out of 10.
I think it's really good.
It's so good.
Like there's something in there.
Yeah.
That's really good, Reggie.
Thank you so much.
She's just lacing us with crack.
That's what it is.
That's the secret ingredient.
Oh, okay.
Oh, yes, that's right.
What is it?
This is beet hummus with lemon juice.
What do I eat with this?
What do you eat with that?
I just eat it straight up.
Oh, um... I mean, I did that last night.
I'm not even lying.
When I was making it last night, I was just like taking some.
Something from the charcuterie board.
Me and Zach have just been smiling at each other every, like, two minutes in this meal.
We just turned each other down.
That is so good, too.
It's like every little thing.
And then you're like, wait, so...
Can you tell us what's in this green sauce?
It's really good.
Also, happy late birthday, Noah.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
I saw your video and I was like, wait, I'm unintentionally... Yeah, wait, I need a photo.
This is so amazing.
Everybody's getting ready to take the picture.
This is so fire.
This is the taste test of the French vanilla peach cake.
We have to.
It's super near.
Yeah, I want it.
It's really good, Reagan.
Thank you.
This is actually like $75 at a restaurant.
Like I would pay $100.
I would rather come here than go to a restaurant.
Easily.
Eat anywhere again.
Food is ruined.
Are you earning the food right now?
She was like, you guys don't have to help.
I'm like, what?
You're not going to make us an incredible meal and we're just going to leave.
That's ridiculous.
We got to do something.
Hard at work.
We have lots of practice together.
Don't let your friends come for you if you're not going to do the dishes out there.
What do you have to say about that?
I was literally expecting it.
Nothing close to us.
And we got a takeout.
Solid some bread, the bread was so good.
You gotta get yourself a friend that knows how to cook.
Goodness, that was fun.
We are at the pool now.
We are going to get a good little... potentially a nap in.
Let the food digest and then we're gonna go swim.
Are you actually gonna sleep?
I might actually sleep.
I'm kind of tired.
But I do need to do a couple things, a couple work things that I'm gonna get done real quick.
But then we'll swim.
Good vibes.
All around.
Wait, this is fire.
You should do the intro right here.
What's up guys, this is episode four of me training my little sister for her half Ironman.
We're gonna go back to Runk Club.
Wait, those are really good, yeah.
Okay, I guess that's the intro.
Is that it?
Wow.
That hit really well.
I'm locked in.
How many am I gonna go?
I think I'm gonna go 2,000.
The goal for me is 2,500 meters.
Just to make sure that I hit my 10k on the week, we are...
Officially eight days after the Chicago River swim.
September 20th and September 12th.
But I'm feeling pretty solid about it.
Like, I'm definitely the best swimming shape I've ever been.
It's pretty nice.
On my birthday two days ago, I did 5,000 yards and it was like casual.
Definitely in pretty good shape, Bob.
What's up, gentlemen?
Are you intrigued?
They're intrigued.
No Anderson on YouTube, check it out.
This is swimming until we say the same word.
Okay, ready?
One, two, three.
Go for it.
I said the wrong word.
I meant beaver.
Drawing and lego.
This is easy.
Okay.
One, two, three.
Instruction booklet.
I was going to say instructions.
Ready?
Yep.
One, two, three.
Robbie Ray.
Robbie Ray?
Oh, this is easy though.
Blue front and Robbie Ray.
I got 2700 meters in at 1 minute and 45 seconds per 100.
That is the third straight month for me of hitting 10,000 yards.
Feels pretty solid.
Well, yeah.
10,000 yards per week.
Third straight month hitting 10,000 yards per week.
And for dinner.
Is that the training day?
I mean, she's kind of beating me in comment.
Engagement on Strava.
343, that was my record.
343 of you commented on her post.
You gotta be locked in on the Strava, guys.
My days typically aren't this fire in terms of eating, but we got some chicken tonight.
Fire.
We got some corn.
The very solid day of food.
And also, this is not a very productive day for me, but it's good to have some of the days that aren't quite as productive.
Right, fifth?
This is not productive.
I just didn't do that much work today.
I know, that's what I'm saying.
It's more important.
No, it was a great day.
It was a phenomenal day.
I'm not saying it wasn't a phenomenal day.
I'm just saying it wasn't.
This isn't like...
Usually, if I was showing a typical day of my life, it would just be like me sitting behind a computer most of the time, so... just for context.
I'm getting better at it.
I'm getting better at giving myself breaks, but not great.
But this was a good example of getting better at it.
So, W-day today.
Robbie Ray, anything to say?
W.
Go be a goat, Noah Anderson.
Do you want me to clip for a minute?
This is dinner.
Give us a tour.
We got chicken, corn, potato, watermelon.
Very excited.
Another phenomenal meal.
Beautiful.
I would say this was a pretty peak day.
Yeah.
It doesn't get much better than this.
We ate so well today.
We really did.
I mean, this right here.
Unsponsored.
It still doesn't get much better than this.
Culver's?
I would take the sponsorship though.
I mean, right here.
Taste test.
This is a Oreo concrete mixer.
It really doesn't get better than this.
10.
10 out of 10.
You know that guy that throws the clashes at the wall?
No.
He's like, how's it going?
You know, too niche, too niche.
Too niche.
Thank you so much for watching this very random vlog.
Appreciate you being here.
And let me know what you want to see next.
Taste test?
Absolutely banger.
Doesn't get much better.
Every single time.